the capitol has long been a symbol of
freedom and democracy across the globe
but the attack
has created shock waves around the world
with american allies and
adversaries responding holly williams
has more on that
from london what happened today in
washington dc is not america
america's allies were horrified the
rampage of the capital
yesterday was a disgraceful act and it
must be
vigorously condemned the leaders of
sister democracies are deeply unsettled
this is a very distressing time in the
united states and i i feel terribly for
what's happening there i really do
and some world leaders pointed the
finger directly at president trump
i unreservedly
in the disgraceful way that they did in
the capital
but it wasn't just america's friends who
watched the assault on the capital
it was america's rivals and enemies and
they
immediately began using it to justify
their own
authoritarian-style rule this is the
state of their democracy
and the mess of the election said iran's
supreme leader ayatollah
controlled media said a ceremonial
procedure in the senate was turned into
a
farce one editorial said it represented
the internal
collapse of the u.s political system and
a russian government spokeswoman said
that the quote split in american society
was the result of an electoral system
that's archaic
and does not meet modern democratic
standards
a cradle of democracy the united states
has long been a symbol of freedom
when american democracy is rocked it
sends shock waves around the world
[Applause]
it looks quite ridiculous said this
russian woman
and this man said it reminded him of the
wild west
for cbs this morning saturday holly
williams london